[Music]
[Applause]
alright this of course is a segment
where viewers try to find mistakes on
our show all right and so far many
challengers but no winners nobody's
actually been able to find a real
mistake so far which is incredible cuz I
know we don't make them we don't make
mistakes
except for that Oh add we just showed
where I didn't know I was in it well
tonight a fan with the YouTube screen
name dancehall C thinks that he's caught
a mistake he has a problem with one of
the titles from a coffee table book
segment we did recently hi Conan on
Tuesday night's show you had a segment
about coffee table books well here's a
new book called and Gettys baby's all
grown up however there was a hyphen in
between the words all and grown having
been an English teacher for several
years I can state with professional
authority that no such - belong there I
hope you'll do the right thing Conan and
fire whoever was responsible for this
gross blunder
so let me get this straight dancehall
see and not only are you saying we
screwed up but you want me to fire the
person responsible well first of all
you're wrong okay that - is fine right
where it is you don't believe me then
maybe you'll take the word of this
linguistic professor from USC misplaced
- you say let me check my resources yes
it says right here
[Applause]
[Music]
oh and one other thing even though
you're wrong I did go ahead because you
asked and fire the graphic designer
who made that book cover and I think so
far he's handling it pretty well
well everyone today is my last day it
was a pleasure working with all of you
[Music]
hello YouTube can I have the home
address of dancehall C please so the
challenge still stands if you think you
can spotted an error on our ship you can
pick up the phone and say hey YouTube
worse hello YouTube
are you saying you've spotted an error
on our show Andy no no no no no I just
got hot it's just he obviously has one
of the special show business guys I
don't know I'm not taking any
submissions for that being an error
we've got you now tell me if you think
you spotted an error on our show report
it team koco.com / ha ha I find an error
we will sort it out right here on the
air let's see if you got what it takes
to meet Chuck mate out of the maestro
we'll take a break